yesterday we had our opening ceremonies
and it's really really nice to meet
everybody the competitors here we see
chris bird here we see
yeah the arbor juniors
they're all
we had the drawing of lots joel benjamin
and the legends uh tony rich in the red
uh t-shirt gregory kaidon gregory
without a beard i didn't recognize him
it just felt so bad who is this guy like
who left this guy
so used to saying kingside diner is
where we are
talking old times with alexander shivala
the mix of the legends and the new
generation of chess players i know it's
so nice crazily enough
uh blitz games didn't break out normally
normally these opening ceremonies you
always gotta
gotta throw in some blitzcake the
players
pick their numbers in this case they
were taking their caps
numbers one through ten the top five
numbers get an extra white
so you should have seen the seniors
arguing over
the extra white they know what number
two means
there oh that's me
look at that
a late a later rival a later rival i
gotta say but i thought shabala did the
best in terms of the style style
he's been playing with this hat for a
couple tournaments now i i'm telling you
it's i i always associated it with the
florida keys florida keys yeah you go to
the islands there and it seems like
everybody's got a
you know pina colada with a little
umbrella and they've got the straw hat
doesn't shabbat live like in the middle
of pittsburgh yeah i know
well he he's trying to stop trying he's
trying he's right want to take our
attention to the game